when drew brees came back for that first
game in late december against the chiefs
and it looked like he wasn't right
that went away quickly he did continue
to heal on the fly we didn't have those
same concerns on christmas day against
the vikings although or i could have
played quarterback that day with alvin
kamara scoring six touchdowns and then
you know when they dismantled the
panthers on sunday 33-7
by all indications however many broken
ribs there were they're healed and drew
brees is fine going into the postseason
uh yes seems fine and honestly you know
since that kansas city game
i've been a little like i've liked what
i've seen from drew brees i feel like
there's been a little bit more of a
concerted effort as a football team to
not necessarily like throw bombs and
everything but but push the ball down
the field you know they had the game the
game against the vikings on christmas
day
to me
one of the most impressive stat lines
i've seen from drew brees in a long long
time a long time you know i i don't sit
here and look at oh 35 for 40 for 280
yards
and you know two touchdowns as a great
thing you know okay yeah i know there's
great completion percentage and it's
decent yardage but i think like 19 for
26 for 311 yards and i know he threw two
interceptions but they were a far more
dangerous offense that day because you
had to worry about defending the whole
field and drew brees when he was
dropping back the pass instead of
looking for four yard gains was looking
for 15 and 20 yard completions and then
that helped camaro start gashing them in
the run game because minnesota was like
whoa they're coming after us today it's
not the dink and dunk offense and if
they can continue that and drew can
continue that i think they are more
dangerous with that approach than they
are of hey we're going to go 12 plays
and 70 yards every drive of the playoffs
against the best defenses in football to
me that's the problem with the saints
that's why they have lost in the
playoffs you got to have some plays
playmakers explosive players you can't
always have the pressure on brees and
sean payton to execute these perfect
drives drive after drive after drive
after drive for three games in a row in
the playoffs against the best defenses
not realistic so
uh i i'm i've been very pleased and
pleasantly surprised is what i'm saying
with drew brees here as of late
and there's been so many weeks where
he's been the question mark he's not
this week the question mark is alvin
camaro returning from the covet 19
reserve list on sunday without
practicing how effective will he be
michael thomas star receiver practicing
yesterday after a stint on injured
reserve due to an ankle that still
wouldn't heal from the injury suffered
way back in week one taste some hill
limited in practice with a concussion so
a lot of questions around brees no
questions about brees and in what will
likely be
his last shot
at getting to a second super bowl and
winning a second super bowl he's going
to be more motivated than ever he is a
high-end competitor we talked about
competitive drive last week with aaron
rodgers drew brees as competitive as
anyone about everything this is it for
him if we believe the things that sean
payton periodically has said this year
this is it for drew brees
and uh maybe may i don't know maybe it
won't be maybe they get caught maybe he
decides remember he told us
at the super bowl that it was actually
the 2017 season that had him thinking
the most about retirement because they
had struggled for so many years before
that if they hadn't had a strong season
in 2017 he may have walked away but i
think this
this
ability to get close
three straight years and now here they
are for four straight years if they
don't finish the job this year will that
be a factor in him saying i'm gonna come
back and give it a try for one more year
because we know they all want to be able
to walk off into the sunset with a super
bowl trophy under their arm yeah well i
know you're right and you know that's
that's that's a rare thing
that's a very rare thing we've you know
am i wrong we've only seen two
quarterbacks in the history of the sport
do that right and they both played for
the denver broncos and peyton manning
and john elway i don't think anybody
else has walked off in that fashion but
you know
it's it's a good question mike
you know if he wins the super bowl
he's out of here right
but if he lost the super bowl in a close
football game or again lost the nfc
championship in a close football game i
would think that makes him yeah think
extra hard about do i give it one more
crack yeah i'm not as good as i was and
all that but i can still win games
playing quarterback and doing that i
think that's a real real possibility
there's no doubt i also wonder do the
saints though really want that i think
that's a fair question to ask on top of
that right right i agree i don't think
they do i think they're ready to move on
i think so i think from drew brees
perspective
the more you stack up these close but no
cigar playoff runs the more tormenting
it will be for you for the rest of your
life after football especially if you
believe
you still could have done it the thing
your dad said that inspired brett favre
to keep playing right he decided at some
point he was going to play until they
ripped the uniform off of me and farve
decided i'm not leaving any years in the
tank and if drew brees leaves a year or
two in the tank and he's got to live
with that for the rest of his life
that may be something he doesn't want to
do that's right maybe he needs the
saints to tell him
no thank you
before he will walk away because if they
would say come on back and he doesn't
and they haven't delivered that second
super bowl win that may be something
that he just can't get proper closure on
his career with chris yeah i mean very
real very real possibility but i would
say to any player you know
play as long as you can
make them push you out the door
make them you know like you just said
rip rip their uniform off you and say
it's over it's done
you know the quote my dad the big effort
that brett favre heard he heard my
father on the radio
and just they were going what would you
tell brett favre and you know big phil
just went well uh you know i tell them
there's only there's only so many rounds
of golf you can play you know i mean
what else you gonna do you know so that
dad dad had their jersey ripped off of
him you know he did he played 15 years
he got elected to the pro bowls last
year but he was one of the first salary
cap casualties in the history of the nfl
he almost came back with some other
teams but he's the perfect person to
listen to in that kind of scenario and i
think that's good advice for drew brees
if you could still do it go after it but
that's going to be a question he'll have
to evaluate after the year where his
body feels how his body feels and
everything like that
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports